on commence avec l'info du jour que se
passe-t-il à nrj 12
et oui alors on a appris aujourd'hui on
appris aujourd'hui que la présentatrice
du mas de mingue ayem est bien font le
ménage d'équipé alors pourquoi tant d
équité quittez donc la chaîne nrj12 et
ragots parmi les ragots rumeurs parmi
les rumeurs elle serait en partance pour
w9 ou le style oui j'ai du secours les
distributeurs le style amc ça regardez
[Musique]
pas de souci pour toi tu te keïta
d'espacé m merci je vois pas où il n'ya
pas de mal mais c'est que tu souhaites
passer à une rupture s'est continuée
vrai que quand on n'est pas bien ici
mais c'est le passé au plus haut les
faits c'est mieux j'adore
[Applaudissements]
ayem pique nique nrj12 bonne mauvaise
nouvelle c'est une très mauvaise
nouvelle pour la chaîne moi j'adore ayem
c'est une étoile quand vous avez une
étoile vous faites tout pour la
conserver nrj 12 un coup c'est le magma
de la téléréalité puis d'autres
émissions on n'y comprend rien donc si
ayem s'en va c'est que la chaîne va
dépérir fait pas quand même à vous
verrez
en fait en janvier ils ont voulu
renégocier les contrats des chroniqueurs
ils ont proposé des baisses de salaires
et des baisses de durée de contrat ayem
a refusé donc elle s'est un peu écarté
du magma galles a laissé sa place à
aymeric aymeric a repris les rênes du
mal mag ça a marché la première après il
ya eu une chute d'audience donc ils ont
rappelé à m
tu vois tu peux parler un peu moins des
[Applaudissements]
on accepterait on te laisse comme ça à
jens est une machine à audience pour
nrj12 bien sûr elle en a ras-le-bol
d'être une machine à audience elle s'est
sentie un petit peu insulté et du coup
elle a voulu se mettre en pause elle a
travaillé enceinte jusqu'au cou elle ne
s'exprime les autres matin y avait pas
beaucoup qui vous travail comme heinze h
et pour vraiment signaler c'est non
c'est non franchement moi j'étais
l'émission amos ah oui c'est vraiment
s'est pris la tête dans son couple avec
son mari parce que ils voulaient qu'elle
arrête
elle n'a pas voulu pour rester avec
stéphane geof qu'elle adore et qu'elle
n'aime vanhove quand on voit ce qu'est
le patron de voile a fait les belles
heures d'énergie directement se refuse à
commenter sur les réseaux sociaux je les
ai eus au téléphone m'a expliqué
pourquoi elle ne veux pas dénigrer
stéphane joffre parce qu'elle aime de
tout son coeur et à une ayem est loyal
et elle ne crache pas sur les gens qui
ont donné à manger
et ça c'est le très bien alors la femme
du sondage bonne ou mauvaise nouvelle
ayem dit énervé doses voici la réponse
bonne nouvelle alors très peu osent
prendre ça peut se prendre la sauce
pondre dans l'est dans les deux ans
c'est une bonne nouvelle
elle va prendre un nouvel envol sur une
autre chaîne je préfère les infos
stéphane qui adore aussi ayem est là
quand ils sont très bons termes
à rappeler ayem en lui disant 'attention
ayem je vais voir si je peux pas te
mettre sont deux programmes parce que je
t'aime et parce que tu corresponds
comptera donc pour l'instant il n'y a
rien de encore voilà d'accord c'est une
professionnelle mais n'allez pas dire
que c'est une machine à audience c'est
une machine à l'audience
un patron de chaîne la place
immédiatement à la tête d'une île
anciennes télévisions
ça c'est vrai que elle jouit d'une
grande notoriété simplement c'est une
maison de chances que se désoler
nettement faire quand le dénouement
avant
de nrj 12 ième opéré dans quoi crime ça
marche très bien c'est le carton de la
scène il n'ya pas l'émission pour ayem
pour l'instant il faudra l'international
en dehors de ces rires éviter stéphane
l'a rappelé aujourd'hui et lui a dit
ayem jeu enfin je ne peux pas qu'on se
veut de te laisser comme ça